I just returned from a doctor's appointment to address changes that need to be made in my thyroid and cholesterol medications.
I blood pressure really started at 199 over 71. The doctor took it again later and it was 204 over 76.
I have had blood pressure issues for years, but never this high, I'm currently taking a bergamut and ubiquadal on a daily basis in order to address these issues.
This doctor tells me that I'm at a very high risk of heart attack or stroke. She is having me monitor my blood pressure again on Monday Wednesday Friday, random times for four weeks.
She predicts that I will need to be at a low dose blood pressure medication.
You have another areas of concern which we have addressed in my recent Zoom call into you should I be concerned about potential side effects going on medication to address these issues that seem to be getting progressively worse.
Okay, so typically they're going to put you on an ACE 2 inhibitor for blood pressure, which would be on a centipril or something like that.
You've got to be careful with blood pressure. White coats in almost extremely common. Could your blood pressure just be high because of those reasons. Yes, I think it was wise that you get a blood pressure cup at home even though those those home blood pressure cups are extremely inaccurate.
It does give you kind of a range of what your blood pressure could be running at.
And if it's much more back within normal range, then you have to think that it's very possible you're just dealing with white coats at will.
Which means your blood pressure goes up just because you're nervous so your blood pressure is very highly responsive to cortisol. And that's not uncommon.
Are there other things to decrease blood pressure other than the centipril interesting study came out.
However, a year is back that showed pulmogranit juice actually works better than an ACE 2 inhibitor.
A pulmogranit juice, just the standard over the counter palm, Brad pulmogranit juice is what was used. Now, I know you could probably buy it organic one and such like that.
I don't know how much pulmogranits are sprayed. I don't know you want to look up the 30 dozen list on that. I don't think it is in that list.
But just using four it was I think the study was using four or six ounces of pulmogranit juice a day lowered a person's blood pressure.
You know, greater than 20 milligrams of the centipril, it was crazy study. So that's something to consider some natural approaches to lowering blood pressure to always when a person has high blood pressure when a person has anything you always are asking the question why what's the most common cause of elevated blood pressure.
It is has to do and that's exactly why ACE 2 inhibitors work. The common so ACE 2 inhibitors block the ACE 2 receptor sites on your smooth muscle cells that are right underneath the end of the all your cells that's around that make up your blood vessels.
So the smooth muscle cells have the ACE 2 inhibitor, ACE 2 receptor and what happens with that ACE 2 receptor is is fired that it causes contraction of the smooth muscles and will effectively increase your blood pressure covers your blood pressure should go up at times of stress and should be down at times.
That's normal, your blood pressure needs to cooperate with stress because it needs to shut blood to your extremities so that you can run away from a predator or something.
But then in a calming time, your parasympathetics should be calming those receptor sites and you should have a normal blood pressure. Now, the problem is that the most common causes of blood pressure are heavy metal toxicity.
Bacterial infection in probably the most common bacterial infection is H. Pylori. These attach to the ACE 2 receptor and fire it causing an increased blood pressure and there's other mechanisms of action that go on with with a bacterial infection like that.
That's why I'm so into H. Pylori.
Before I treated H. Pylori dealing with H. Pylori. So you want to look at that as a possibility too.
So this is the things you look at blood pressure issues.
The common treatment for it also is NAD and nitric oxide, things like that but you have to be careful with those because that also increases epithelial growth factor of cancer.
The person has cancer, you have to be careful with some of the natural approaches or cardiac issues and the ethereal issues. I blood pressure issues, you would treat them kind of opposite. So you have to be careful with some of the natural approaches to those things.
So yeah, so I know this question I think was posted that I should have answered it a week ago I think so if you're still having questions make sure you get a hold of it.